his ratification of the withdrawal
agreement as approved by the UK
government and endorsed by this
Parliament and also by the European
Council ten days ago the European
Council followed the request of the
extension of article 15 till the 22nd of
May on the condition that the House of
Commons approve withdrawal deal before
the 29th of March unfortunately that
didn't happen making reference to the
statement by the Prime Minister of the
UK last night I say that though we have
a few days left if the UK is in a
position of approving the withdrawal
deal with a viable majority by the 12th
of April then the UK in that case should
also the European Union would also
accept an extension until the 22nd of
May 12th of April is the final date for
possible approval if the House of
Commons does not adopt a stance before
that date no extension no short-term
extension will be possible after the
12th of April we run the risk of
jeopardizing the correct running of the
European elections and the correct
functioning of the European Union the
withdrawal agreement has always been a
compromise a balanced compromise which
has enabled both parties to personally
obtain what they wanted but not
everything that they wanted its with
that kind of compromise that the
European Union has been built from the
beginning it's that kind of compromise
which has enabled the European project
to move on and it's that kind of
compromise
that we need now
a great part of the debate in the House
of Commons has been about the future
relationship between the EU and the UK
the EU is prepared to add a certain
degree of flexibility to the political
declaration in order to open the door to
a close partnership between the EU and
the UK in the future we're open to a
whole panoply of different options it
could be a free-trade agreement it could
be a customs union or a European
Economic Area we've been open since the
beginning we see this in the political
declaration the EU is prepared to begin
discussions negotiations on our future
partnership as soon as the withdrawal
deal is signed even before the ink is
dry the Commission team is ready to go
my friend
Michele Barney our chief negotiator is
ready and I would like to see the same
level of preparation on the side of the
UK whether or not that happens depends
entirely on the UK European Council has
given all necessary time and space to
the UK to take its decision I believe a
No Deal on the 12th of April at midnight
has become a scenario which looks more
and more likely it's not what I want but
we have made sure that the EU is ready
to face up to that situation we've been
preparing since December 2017 we've
always known that the logic of article
50 makes no deal a default option we've
known for a long time what the balance
of powers is in the House of Commons the
Commission has
has published 91 notes on brexit
preparation 32 logistic proposals 3
communications we've been to each one of
the 27 member states to help them to
prepare we have organized a 72 seminars
with member states the measures that
member states and ourselves have taken
will attenuate the harshest impact of
the shock of a No Deal they offer true
protection they will guarantee that
citizens of the EU and the UK will
continue to live and work wherever they
reside now it will make sure that
aeroplanes will continue to be able to
take off and land we have adapted our
financial instruments in order to assist
the fishing sector we have determined
the mechanisms which will enable us to
continue our police cooperation and
we've taken all necessary measures to
attenuate the disruption in the
financial markets and the measures that
we have taken are temporary in nature
they are unilateral they will protect
the key interests of the Union at least
until the end of the year but the
disturbances suffered by citizens
businesses in almost all sectors will be
unavoidable the UK will be more affected
than the EU because a managed or
negotiated No Deal does not exist any
more so than a transition period for a
No Deal
whatever happens the UK will have to
respond to the three main questions of
the separation one citizen's rights they
must be respected and protected - the UK
will have to continue to honor its
financial commitments taken as
member-state and three a solution will
have to be found for the island of
ireland preserving peace and the single
market the UK must respect the spirit
and the letter of the Good Friday
Agreement no withdrawal agreement does
not mean no commitment and the three
questions that I've just mentioned will
not disappear overnight
they will constitute strict conditions
for rebuilding trust and launching
discussions on the future la next week
in the European Council we will hear
Teresa may the prime minister explaining
her intentions and we will decide what
to do the principles that will guide my
action are limpid we will work together
Member States and the European Union
will work together to avoid a no deal
situation until the last minute the only
ones that would benefit from a No Deal
are those that are against a world order
based on rules the only ones that will
be strengthened will be the populace and
nationalists
the only ones who will be delighted will
be those who wish to weaken the European
Union and of course the UK the EU will
not expel any member state together with
Michele we will do everything possible
to avoid a disorganized exit working
together with the governments of the 27
and the European Parliament encouraging
them to do the same including the UK is
the first time that I've read a speech
in this Parliament because I believe
that each and every word has its
importance thank you for listening